jumping into why I get to talk to you so
something that really surprised me about
the show was that it is not like the
Disney Plus shows before uh there's this
one has a little bit what I call um
violence that is more representative of
like a Netflix Marvel show than a Disney
Plus show I'm on board with this I like
this um uh can you sort of talk about
how it's more for maybe
adults yeah
it's going to be more of course a lot of
blood violence guns involved as well and
it's very gritty and it's a different
feel compared to what the Other M MCU
stuff that we've seen
and now that it's being uh maturely
rated it's more intense do you view Maya
as more of a hero or more as a
villain I would say she's an in between
an anti-hero more like that sure I uh
you could see though how some people can
view her in sort of both
ways yes you can definitely see it in
both ways it's kind of she has this very
nice balance that she's trying to Center
and she's starting to open up a little
bit later as the story progresses
progresses we'll see how she opens up
and how she becomes an anti-hero at the
end of the story um I don't want to do
spoilers however what do you think
people will be thinking or saying after
they see the
finale I think people will be like
that's all that's it I want more what's
gonna happen
next
I you know we never know where Ma is
gonna go next so I think that they'll
all be curious about that sure when you
were seeing what you were going to film
you saw the schedule what was the day
that you had circled because you were
incredibly excited to film it or you
were very nervous to film
it I remember being so nervous doing the
scene with Kingpin and I remember
looking on the call sheet for the next
day and seeing how it was such an
intense emotional scene and I would say
oh crap emotional scenes are always just
so tough for me especially with one of
the top rated actors you know working
alongside him Vincent nafo so I was very
nervous about that particular scene and
I remember looking forward to it and the
stunt team you know the training team we
did at the skating rink as well those
were very those were scenes I was
looking forward to a lot uh what do you
think it actually is why does Kingpin
why do you think Kingpin cares so much
about Maya versus say some of the other
people in his
life because he trusts Maya so much and
it's obvious that Maya has bowed down to
him and red him as this High entity
basically her whole life they love each
other so much and Kingpin has you know
it's kind of crazy how Kingpin can
forgive her after she shot him in the
head but they just love each other so
much that it's just very interesting to
see that I'm curious what you might want
to tease about Maya's possible Powers
slash things that have been hinted at in
the first few
episodes it is related her powers are
related to her culture that's all I kind
of want to give right now you'll see
more in the series sure um what one of
the things though about the series is
that uh I I say this all the time but
it's so true representation matters and
it matters uh for so many people and so
can you sort of talk a little bit about
what it means for you to
represent to just be a part of a show
like this and showing what you can do
and what so many people you know what I
mean I I don't think I put I think I
butchered the question or what I was
trying to
say no I yeah I think it's really
important that we have this
representation in the community I have
three different communities that I'm
able to represent the indigenous the
deaf and the ampute community so those
all communities are all very under
represented so having this role and
being able to educate people and uplift
this awareness that we have for all of
these communities communities I able to
represent is so great and and the
community deserves to
have their voices and their stories be
heard so I'm excited for the audience to
be able to learn about all of those
communities on that note I just want to
say congratulations and I wish you
nothing but the best and I really do
hope this show is a huge hit for you
guys oh thank you so
much